enfin nous entamons aujourd'hui terrible
en bretagne c'est une grande région
français c'est une action qui comporte
combien de débats recevoir monsieur fin
ça non
oui parce que vous êtes arrêt
de prendre de risque mais qui est tout
étonné de voir tant que client autour
d'elle puisque tant parce que tous les
amis qui étaient là sur la place en face
ont suivi nous sommes tous prêts de vous
pour parler un peu fleur maintenant est
ce que ce sont des couleurs de bretagne
les nains partout
en valeur en bretagne
oui
les étrangers les gens de passage majid
toumane haïti attendait qu'est ce qui se
passe ici j'en fais une musique
incroyable qui s'approche de nous je
vous quitte le second
alors rempli balouche complet
complètement alors voilà et je verse au
milieu de la place pie ix très chaude
qui fument
et j'étais content avec ça alors j'étale
l'aube avec la louche mais avec une
raclette angoua g talent la faf se
souvient de quatre roulés sur la large
de la frange se déplaçant à fait
régulière voilà est-ce que c'est bien
comme ça